this drivers cabin of a 15-ton harvester
is being assembled by hand German
machine construction more than 700
kilometers away from London but the
brexit decision does not seem so far
away
especially for Winnie Walcott of
Manchester some of my colleagues have
said start packing your bags and head
back to England of course that's just
robust humour among colleagues Winnie
Walcott has worked in Germany for more
than 25 years his employer was not
amused by the brexit the class company
sells large agricultural machines all
over the world including in the UK
before the referendum the company
invested millions in distribution in
Britain but with the pound falling the
prices of the machines will effectively
rise for British farmers we decided last
year to expand our distribution in
Britain we'll stick with this decision
because the market will still be there
in the future so this is a
future-oriented investment that will pay
off because in Britain most agricultural
technology is imported Britain has no
significant production of agricultural
machinery so the playing field will
remain level for all the competitors
that means that everyone who exports
agricultural machinery to Britain faces
the same problem
how much high tech will British farmers
be able to afford in the future that
depends on the bricks of negotiations
and how customs and subsidies develop
it's important to find solutions as fast
as possible rather than procrastinating
uncertainty is always bad for everyone
concerned especially in business so we
need negotiations as soon as possible
and Britain should prepare itself
properly because my impression is that
the British aren't prepared at all for
this situation
they're only now beginning to think
about what it could mean
Winnie Walcott has some forebodings
about what the brexit could mean
I haven't got a good feeling about it
now because everything is going to get
more expensive and if unlike a lot of
English people they like going on
holidays and it once you go into the
continent everything is gonna cost you
more money the changes in prices customs
duties and economic growth that Britain
faces will also affect companies in
Germany and elsewhere that export to
Britain